Switzerland used to be called Helvetica
like the font. It all started back in
like 58 B.C. when this guy, Julius Caesar,
conquered this part of Europe and suddenly
it was a part of the Roman Empire and adopted
a Latin name that was named after the tribe,
the Helvetii tribe. I don’t know if I'm
pronouncing that right. But I did my best. Okay,
but this isn’t just ancient history. This is still
what Switzerland is kind of called today. Swiss
Internet domains are “.ch” and that stands for
Confoederatio– Conf– Ugh, I can't I cannot say
this. Confoe– And that stands for Confoederatio
Helvetica, the Helvetic– the Helvetic
Confederacy. I mean, my website is johnnyharris.ch
because I love Switzerland. Now, Helvetica
the font. It was originally called Neue Haas
Grotesk. Not exactly the catchiest, prettiest
sounding name. At least that's what Linotype, the
German company that bought the font, thought. So
they decided to rename it to Helvetica after
Switzerland, where it was developed. And I'm
sure that the name change helped it become one
of the most loved fonts in the world. All because